stalking with Gregg train yesterday and
you can complain about something where
you can embrace this is one of the big
things that kind of learn from you and
this is like when you look at your own
situation compared to other you know
past situations that are way worse right
so one you start with okay your your
situation isn't that bad that's what you
start with then you go on to okay my
situation these are small teeny tiny
town challenges that all you have to do
is approach you in this way of like
embracing it you know how like um like
anything okay anytime you're feeling
frustrated about your situation or
whatever right and really in person when
you put it in perspective these are
small challenges that you just gotta
overcome you take it on as it's like
yeah you want to put more work on my
plate at work cuz I can handle it
because I can handle it but and I'll do
it the best and watch me work you know
that is good and interesting you know
when when we had Tim Ferriss on here and
when I did Tim Ferriss is an interview
the first time I was on his podcast and
he it's the thing that I talked about
when he came on here like i he asked the
question sort of saying hey how close do
you get to the darkness before it
consumes you and I've talked about
before you know if you stare into the
soul of a monster you have to be careful
because you might become a monster yeah
and so I mean I I think yeah there's the
drugs that she got put on obviously
played a role but she got in this world
where all she saw was the bad yeah and I
think that too Tim Ferriss his point
where he was saying to me like hey how
often should I get close to the darkness
you know how often should I look at that
and you know my response was hey you in
order to know the light you got to know
the darkness but you can absolutely go
too far in that direction yeah and you
can say to yourself wow the world is
evil and everyone's evil and underneath
the surface everyone could turn into
this Imperial Japanese soldier and
commit these atrocities and that is what
you absolutely
and I would say be careful I don't know
if that's the right word I guess it is
the right word be careful but to me what
you have to do is you have to balance it
and to me as an American as a man
there's so much good right I think that
people generally get get jaded to all
the good that's out there and that's why
I say hey you know what look over here
at the darkness but for someone that's
stuck in a horrible place in a horrible
situation in life that's those those
folks gotta look out and say wait a
second there's not there's so much good
out there you know if you can take it
like that's clearly I mean you look at
look at iris Chang I mean she is smart
and successful and beautiful and
well-liked and had a good she came up
with an amazing family her parents were
adored her right she had every thing in
her life was good right and she lost all
that she you know what it's like if you
talk to anybody that flies planes right
if you go into a cloud you lose your
orientation it happens in diving too it
happens when you're surfing if you if
you fall off a big wave and you're
getting rolled around and sometimes it
can be hard to tell which way is up
right it can happen you know guys drive
drive their airplanes they get lost in
the clouds they drive their airplanes
into a mountain or they drive it into
the ground because they don't they get
disoriented and they lose sight of which
way is up and you or you're underwater
and you lose sight of which way is up
that's what you have to watch out for
you got to be able to say wait a second
if everything is black around me okay
stop you know let me get oriented let me
finish my control panel in the water
it's real easy you gotta look for
bubbles which way or the but where are
the bubbles bubbles are gonna go up and
so when you get trapped in that darkness
these people end up in these situations
where everything looks black
stop mm-hmm you're disoriented you you
just can't see you don't know the right
direction it's okay
figure out where the bubbles are they're
gonna go to the surface and when they
get to the surface there's gonna be
light and you're gonna be okay but
obviously iris she got trapped
dragged down and disoriented in the
darkness and she couldn't figure out
that she had a
bend in a Sun and a family and money and
she had all these beautiful things in
her life
yeah which a lot of times especially if
you go full speed in that direction
where you don't know which way is up so
you're going down even the good things
that come in you know like even you know
don't get paranoid something good and
you're like that's bad for instance for
instance she's on a trip in Louisville
gonna go do the speech or whatever and
someone's checking her in the hotel
maybe someone was saying oh I think
that's Irish shanghaied sorrentine right
instead she's thinking oh it's some
nationalists that are coming to get me
yeah so yeah she was absolutely so
that's something that that I think and
it's something that for for those of us
that are not in that situation how do
you pay attention and observe people and
make sure that your friends or people
you know or people that are in bad
situations how do you make sure that
they're getting enough that they know
how to orient themselves and get back to
the surface and get away from all that
horribleness when you approach thing and
I was talking to Greg that's kind of
what it and this just reminded me of it
when you approach things like that you
you know how like you said you're going
that if you don't know which way is up
you're going down a good thing you're
gonna look at that's a bad thing
reinforcing my whole direction by the
way so if you approach it in a way where
things that even would be frustrating to
like an everyday person if you approach
it like good um you know I'm the one to
do this thing bring the challenge
because the challenges are good you know
if that's the approach that will
reinforce that way of thinking yes so
yes you will be going you know that and
really when you export darkness that's
not to embrace the darkness and be dark
like I said don't become the dead that's
basically you're trying to avoid
ignorance that's what you're doing yeah
because you got no dark interest it's a
controversy okay guess what this in in
for this case I mean obviously I I pray
and never have to read anything as
heinous as that again ever on the show
let me - but that happened yeah right
that happened yeah that happened we
should not you shouldn't go through life
and not realize that that happened yeah
that that happened to you that human
being said that to other human beings
as horrible it as it is you need to
realize that that is a part of our human
history so that way you can say you
could you recognize and say okay this is
this can happen and we need to watch out
for it and yeah so look out for your
friends keep them knowing that there's
no keep them knowing which direction
they're heading in and you see someone
going sideways bring them grab them
especially with the I mean this is kind
of a it's specific to this story but the
the drugs you know when you take
Medicaid because that's a big one man
it can mess up your pretty even like how
you said when you get off the drugs
right you know cuz these are all
chemical things in your brain made for
certain things for sure so when that
part goes sideways
you can't like reason necessarily with
someone you know they can't reason with
you can't reason with yourself you know
stuff that would seem obvious hey if I
you know walk off this cliff it's
obvious that's bad it doesn't really
work that way if like your chemicals are
off generally so yeah you kind of gotta
you know like look out for somebody if
you can see that happening yeah no doubt
and it's very it's very interesting the
the mind is so incredibly durable but at
the same time circle it's just totally
fragile and a little some little change
to the to the composition or to the to
the chemicals that are in or to the
thought patterns that are in yeah you
know can be really drastic changes on a
person yeah
you ever have a real bad flu and a fever
and then you're trying to sleep and it's
almost like a mix between dreaming
hallucinating and like cuz man it's like
your thoughts are all jumbled up okay
you want you want to tell you an echo
story right now yes this will be a
stupid echo story so brace yourself
awesome so I was like point I was 23
years old something
and I was doing the dishes speaking of
doing the dishes I was doing the dishes
and I turned on the water and I didn't
see what was happening but this little
stream a tiny little stream of water had
had broken through the pipe at some
point in the handle and it and it
started to land on my hand well I didn't
know that it was water because it must
have been like a similar temperature to
what my body was at the time and so I
see this and it looks for for a quarter
of a second it looks like my hand is
blistering it's just it's spreading so
rapidly and for a quarter of a second I
thought to myself I'm being attacked by
chemical warfare and I'm gonna die in
the next next half a second I'm dead I
think we're doing some chemical warfare
training or whatever and so at that
moment for about a half a second I
thought I'm about to die and it only
lasted about then I'd realize it was
water and I said oh but my point is that
mentally yeah well if you know a
different situation I could get locked
into that mode and when you see iris go
hey these people are coming after me
yeah if you get mentally locked in that
mode and you start seeing things that
are that that you you start imposing or
overlaying your reality over actual
reality you start augmenting reality
yourself that gets really really scary
yeah like when you think someone's mad
at you I read that you think someone's
mad at you so you're looking for all the
little fuse you know thing is this
person had him here or are they not in
normal everyday stuff you know who I
didn't why she texted me back quickly
yeah one for five minutes
I know usually she puts a smiley face no
smiley face this time you know it's you
yeah she's mad I know she's mad
something's wrong but yeah so yeah if
you have meanwhile they're like well
don't tell me you're talking about yeah